diets can be hard to follow and some of
them don't even work well dr nash in
total transformation the sponsors of
this segment they have the solution take
a look
when i started with dr nash i weighed
over 300 pounds and i was pre-diabetic
since being on a program i lost over 130
pounds and i no longer have that
pre-diabetic threat dr nash laura's
transformation her weight loss it's
unbelievable i want to start off this
week i have some stats here on diets and
weight loss that i want you to unpack
first okay okay
the average american woman goes on six
to eight diets a year
in 12 months 96 of people gain back the
weight after doing a traditional diet
and for 80 of people tracking calories
and exercise does not cause permanent
weight loss your program works you went
through a big weight loss journey how
did everything work for you
so i actually discovered this on my own
because i was overweight since i was
eight years old and i had done diet
after diet i'd probably easily done 36
different types of diets chasing weight
loss but never really seeing a decent
result or a result that would stick and
the diet the doctors could never find
anything wrong so there was always this
message that it was my behavior it was
my willpower i just needed to try harder
but after i became a chiropractor i
actually was able to do my own testing i
found out that i was pre-diabetic with a
fatty liver and when i focused on
reversing the damage that's when i lost
the 80 pounds right you talk about
focusing on the damage don't most dices
come down to eating less and moving more
you would think so right because that
just sounds like it's logical but it's
not biological and so no in fact most
commercial diets are going to encourage
the problem to worsen by using tactics
like eat what you want and still lose
weight or providing lifetime memberships
in their programs which means they're
building the failure right into the
technique and then they push deprivation
and tr and tactics that rely on
willpower and motivation and the problem
is that never works long term and that's
just what they want they want you to
lose weight not hold a normal weight so
this way you come back to them and you
use the program again that's eye opening
right there that is eye opening how is
your program different then my program
is different in three ways so yes we do
get the body to lose weight but we're
not just focused on losing weight we're
focused on burning body fat primarily on
using strategies for fat loss the second
thing that we're going to do is we're
going to customize that program to
target that person's underlying issues
that's driving the weight problem to be
stubborn and then the third thing that
we actually do is we prove to the client
that their body will hold the weight
loss while they are eating two to three
thousand calories a day if that program
cannot prove to you that your body will
hold the weight loss afterwards then
it's probably a temporary program jc and
every week you bring a special what do
you have for us this week dr nash
so normally when i do the one-on-one
evaluation because we do have to figure
out what's going on that's driving that
stubborn weight problem that's 97 but
whenever las vegas now allows me to come
on and talk to jc and talk to you guys i
always want to do something special so
we have 10 spots available they are 9.97
for that online evaluation it is online
they sell out quickly so get your spot
now but let me see what's going on
inside that body that's stopping you not
only from losing weight but holding a
normal weight
thanks again to total transformation for
sponsoring this segment las vegas now